another opening
another show
that's all the singing you're getting
out of me so
in an effort to try and alleviate my
schedule a little bit as we get into the
holidays and i get stuck into multiple
major projects because i'm a [ __ ] who
can't juggle my schedule worth a dang
uh how about a nice fun easy list and
what's more fun than musicals movie
musicals
specifically so a couple of ground rules
before i give you
my top 10 picks for movie musicals
i am allowing for movies that were
originally staged
versions however anything like that is
going to be judged on the merit of the
film not the stage version
i am not including animated films here
otherwise
half the list would be disney so this is
live action only
and i'm going to be really specific to
what i
consider a musical which to me
means that the characters just burst
into song
with like i've got one or two weird semi
exceptions but like say for instance i
saw some lists of musicals and things
like pitch perfect came up
which has a ton of singing but
characters don't
burst into song in a way that they do in
what i consider musicals
they are singers in a singing
competition that's why people are
singing
it's explained in universe it could
happen in the real world
in my mind it's not a musical unless
they are doing something that if it
happened in reality everyone will go
what the heck are you doing but it just
gets to happen
that to me is a musical that's what i'm
including here we've got ground rules
let's do a top ten
[Music]
number ten white christmas
yeah i'm going to be jumping all over
the place for this one
and let's start with something that
feels nicely seasonal you're not going
to see a whole lot of
older musicals on here because a lot of
them had a tendency to do something that
i don't like as much which is to
basically stop the story in order to
have a musical number
whereas i tend to prefer songs that
actually move the plot forward in some
way
now white christmas that's not the case
for every song
but the songs are so good the vibe is so
wonderful on this and even songs that
like have nothing to do with the story
they're practically non-sequiturs like
choreography
is just so dang entertaining
i can't help but love it
[Music]
number nine singing in the rain
now a lot of people will put this a lot
higher but again it does have at times
that sense of
they're bending the story in a direction
as an excuse to have a musical as
opposed to
having a story and just having
characters burst out into song
as that story goes along now it's not as
egregious on that
front as white christmases which is why
it gets a higher rank and also the
production on this
is a little bit of a higher caliber they
do a little bit more whoa
okay with it but on top of that it's
funny it's entertaining even the
non-musical bits are a riot
it's uh it's a really good time
[Music]
number eight repo
the genetic opera now this one this
one's really a matter of taste
because i have plenty of friends heck my
partner liz
does not like this it is not her jam at
all
and i get it this thing if you
cannot tune into its wavelength not only
will you not like it
you will be actively turned off by it
it's really off-putting if you can't
tune into it
but if you can
it is really something special it is a
rock opera with the emphasis
on opera big bombastic
operatic story and characters people
bursting into song with their plans of
revenge and their
emotions the entire thing is cranked up
to 11.
i find the songs catchy as heck and i
love the visual presentation the cast is
great
[Music]
number seven willy wonka
and the chocolate factory i actually
kind of debated this one for a little
while because part of me was wondering
am i giving the whole thing a pass just
because
pure imagination is so perfect
and it is but there are other good songs
here as well
the opalumpa songs are nice and they
move things along at a good pace
even the songs that take place earlier
on i've got a golden ticket it's nice
it's catchy
this is a good fully fledged musical
it's a little harder for me to watch as
an adult
you know realizing how limited the
budget was in
at some times and feeling that some of
the
supporting characters don't have a lot
going for them but
you know what the songs are good in gene
wilder
as willy wonka especially when he's
singing
[Music]
number six chicago
this is the one where i am kind of
bending my own rules a little bit
because
technically speaking they do have a
mechanism in universe for why they
characters aren't
actually bursting into song because it's
kind of going on in roxy's head
but it is so stylized and it is stylized
in the way that those types of musicals
are i am allowing it
this is a phenomenal cast perfectly
handled and honestly
i think it's better than the stage
version by quite a bit
and actually because of that thing i
just mentioned that extra layer
because chicago as entertaining as it is
on stage
it's a very superficial show it doesn't
have
layers but the film does just by having
this be
something that she's imagining and
getting to contrast that with what's
really happening gives it way more depth
on film than it has on stage
it's a fun dance and song
show on stage that's really kind of all
it is this found a way to do more with
it
number five the greatest showman
ladies and gents this is the moment you
waited for i probably would have put
this higher if i didn't have my
reservations about sort of the myth
making
around someone like pt barnum i
i've done a full video before about that
topic and how i
kind of wish they'd done an original
character who was clearly be pt
barnum esque but not the man himself
but setting that aside which some people
can't
if you can't set that aside i don't
blame you but if you can
oh man these songs just
kick butt all of them there is not
a bad song in the bunch every single
song
it slaps i feel ridiculous saying that
because like
that using that phrase is probably going
to date this video awfully but
like they do all the songs are great the
way
that they are shot and the way that
everything is
framed and pulled together it feels much
you can tell
that it was a musical created for a film
and not
adapted from the stage it's
wonderful
[Music]
number four the muppet movie
i had several options i
knew i wanted a muppet movie on this
list and i debated
i decided i was gonna limit it to just
one muppet movie
and i went back and forth between this
one the
muppets from 2011 and i'm up at
christmas carol
and that's not to say that those are the
best muppet movies ever
but judging them as musicals
specifically
but ultimately i gotta come back to the
original
part of it has to do with how well each
song that a song
embodies the character that gets to sing
it part of it is just for rainbow
connection
and i mean there's other great songs
every song in this thing is great
moving right along can you picture that
the magic store at the end they're
all phenomenal and told in this
wonderful meta anarchy
fashion that only the muppets can pull
off as well as they do
here number three
the rocky horror picture show if i were
ranking these 100
purely on the subjective scale of how
much does it mean to me
personally i would have put this at
number one now granted how much they
mean to me personally is a heavy factor
in here but i did not want it to be the
only
factor and there are some things about
this in terms of
consent i suppose is going to be the big
one
that do make me go
like i still love it but i have friends
who can't watch it because of some of
the
dubious consent scenes that are in this
and that's fair
but this thing means so much to me
this is another one i've done a whole
video on why
i love it so much what it meant to me
for seeing it at 13 years old
and just not feeling so
strange it means a lot
this movie and the songs are
amazing so many great songs
time warp sweet transvestite i'm going
home oh that one breaks my heart
and it's such a unique piece of work
nobody has really been able to recapture
what this film
did it's something special
[Music]
number two the one that i might
regret i have a tendency sometimes to be
a little bit prisoner of the moment and
to have things that are
new i i sometimes i overvalue them and
then in hindsight i'm like no that
should have been lower and maybe that'll
be the case here but you know what i
still want to put this here right now
rocket man how did it take
this long with so many
decades worth of
biopics about musicians
before somebody thought hey
we can actually use their music to tell
their life story
not in like and here's where they wrote
this song and here's where they wrote
this
no make it a musical
let the song tell us
as an audience who they are and take us
on the journey across their life
and if you're gonna do that with anybody
elton john
if you're gonna make a musical out of
somebody's discography
that's a good one to go with because his
music
and his life was big enough
theatrical enough that it all fits and
flows
amazing lead performance all the
performances are good
now obviously the songs weren't written
for this as a musical but
it doesn't feel like a jukebox musical
it feels like
these songs tell his story
it's phenomenal now before we get to
number one i have a couple of honorable
mentions i want to touch on
these were in contention but just edged
out
little shop of horrors great music the
effects are
very cool uh honestly there are
parts of it that they dip and are a bit
of a lull for me it doesn't
it never completely loses me but it does
i do kind of want to fast forward
through some bits of this one
oliver this one's partly nostalgia
because
i got the performance bug
by playing the role of fagin in seventh
grade
uh in the stage version of this so
part of it is nostalgia it's a good
movie besides
it's it's a lot of fun but i didn't want
to buoy it up too much just because of
my personal attachment to it
pink floyd the wall i was initially
determined to have this on the list but
when i really stopped and thought about
it
the characters don't actually burst into
song
except for the times when pink is on the
stage all the songs are simply laid over
the events happening like it's a music
video it's
not a proper musical and on that basis
for the rules i decided to make i
couldn't include but i need to give it
an honorable mention here
this thing is one of a kind and finally
mary poppins i know there are some
people going to call me philistine for
the fact that this didn't make the list
proper and
spoiler sound of music is not at number
one it's not on the list at all
not that they're bad i don't dislike
these things i'm just not
in absolute love with them the way a lot
of people
are maybe it's because i didn't grow up
on sound of music i did grow up with
mary poppins which is why that one gives
the honorable mention
and finally number one
it's a little bit nostalgia it's a
little bit
milestone in filmmaking it's a little
bit iconic
it's a little bit of a lot of things
that make it
the wizard of oz i don't know
if this was the first musical i ever saw
it might have been but regardless of
whether or not it was you know what it
feels like it was
it feels like the first time to be
transported to a world
where black and white can become color
people can
burst into song a lion
is a coward a scarecrow needs brains
a tin man needs a heart and a witch
can cackle her head off and terrify
children
across decades this is easily
one of the most iconic films ever
made and all the singing is terrific
judy garland of course but
everybody has great songs and despite it
coming from the
era that usually had songs that stopped
the story
the songs moved the story forward they
tell
you about the characters they give you
information that you
weren't really getting otherwise it
gives you the full picture
they don't divert the plot to give you
these songs they integrate the songs
into it in many ways the film's ahead of
its time in terms of this level of
integration
of the singing and the narrative they're
not at odds they're not
competing with each other they are one
and the same
it's really hard to beat something this
magical so that's it for this one folks
my personal picks for the 10 best movie
musicals what are yours
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about them you
are not obligated to use the same
restrictive rules that i did
do your list however you want to do your
list usual stuff like share subscribe
i've got the patreon which is how i pay
my bills and it keeps this whole thing
up and running keeps me
fed if you're able to contribute in any
amount i greatly appreciate it
even if you don't that's okay because at
the end of the day
you are the council i'm only running the
meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
um
[Music]